let's go to the phones today 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 okay let's go next to Matthew
Matthew is holding on what's going on
nothing I did it
that's much really but the 17
investigations I'm just wondering what
your thoughts are on which one do you
think is the most important that they
should focus on
you mean the 17 Trump investigations you
know at this point it honestly could be
more than 17 I know 17 is a popular
number to throw around but it actually
could be could could be even more than
that I think that there's a couple of
great the most important ones to me are
definitely whether there was criminality
in terms of trying to end the Russia
investigation obstruction of justice etc
I think that the lies and coordination
around the Trump Tower
a Moscow project are a big deal you know
it's it's so hard to say because there's
just so much the direction of Michael
Cohen
to commit felonies is something that
needs to be looked into it's an
embarrassment of riches but you know the
thing is Matthew if none of these end up
having consequences is it all going to
matter in the end that that's true to
follow up on that like if they do though
if they do have consequences do you
believe it'd be good to impeach him and
remove him or do you think that we
should just split mountain and then
because this would probably hurt his
chances of winning in twinkling maybe
yeah I guess exodia the way but what do
you think I'm really split on this
because if there is the impeachment and
vote to remove Trump assuming Michael
Mike Pence is not implicated he becomes
president does that give him a good
position to be elected in 2020 and hips
if so I believe he could also be elected
again in 2024 because he his first term
would be the twenty20 tournament that's
very dangerous
so I ultimately don't know I've sort of
generally said that I think the best
situation is a scandal-ridden Trump who
loses in 2020 the thing is a lot of the
trumpets are standing by
guy even despite what's going on so I
don't know I'm as perplexed as you are
Matthew um thank you appreciate the
coffee thank you so much I am thrilled
to tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink asam /
hackman blinka is a really unique
service for your phone tablet and web
browser and it is incredibly useful for
people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blink as'
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube
i've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa ke ma n